american craft beer week is an annual
springtime salute to local beer
and local breweries and it just so
happens to be this week
here to tell us ways we can celebrate is
dave pasquale from big dogs brewery
and wendy forest from craft house
brewery welcome you guys
dave let's start with you how is big
dogs celebrating
american craft beer week oh we're
celebrating in many ways but
uh you know we're doing some pretty cool
beer cocktails here uh we're infusing
some of our beers and to say a burgerita
we're doing a hazy
uh type of burgerita we're doing a dirty
dog mojito
we're doing things like that but we're
also trying to showcase our beer by
giving customers a dollar off wearing
and supporting us by wearing their big
dog's t-shirts or anything
that you could wear i don't know this
heat i guess you wouldn't wear a hoodie
but come on in we'll give you a dollar
off but
even if you don't have that we can give
you 20 off and get one of our uh
uh gear hat you name it you can you can
get something to sporting we'll give you
a dollar off your whole time buying beer
i love it wendy the last time you were
on las vegas now i was out there with
you actually at craft house and
literally seconds before we went on the
air i spilled a beer so hopefully
there was no beer spilling out there
what are some ways that you are
celebrating downtown this week
so craft house is celebrating american
craft beer week by releasing our most
popular beer
um that is called savoy that's a
strawberry mochi milkshake ipa
but we are celebrating all across the
valley with all of our southern nevada
breweries
[Music]
awesome dave they say that local beer is
better so where do you see the future of
local breweries where you see the future
going
uh i just see you know uh beer has
changed we've seen the market has kind
of shifted to
more localized uh type of support so
you know we're really pushing hard we
really want the support of the vegas
locals to come out and support our small
businesses
none of us are really big breweries so
you know we need that support of the
local uh
you know community to come and showcase
or actually come and we can showcase
what we can do you know we have a lot of
great beers award-winning beers uh you
know recognized beers and things like
that
awesome i don't know some people don't
know about it you know come check us out
we got a lot of cool stuff
check it out we appreciate it you guys
we're running out of time celebrate
national craft beer week it's this week
more las vegas now is coming up